hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in today's video we're
going to be reviewing
australian fitness youtuber chloe ting
with over 3 million subscribers on
youtube
and a bunch of popular workout programs
chloe has become a
household name in the fitness space but
before we get into the review
a big reminder to subscribe to the
channel and click the little bell so
that you never
miss an upload also my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for entertainment
and educational purposes only and you
should always speak to your health care
provider about your
unique needs also while we do watch an
entire work day's worth of content
we cannot catch a youtuber's entire
catalog
so please keep in mind that what you see
may not fully reflect a full creator's
diet
finally a reminder to please be kind in
the comments both in mine
and in chloe's let's keep this a
supportive learning space
now before we get into the actual food
i want to mention that in a lot of
chloe's what i in a day videos
she references that she tends to get
really bloated
and upon doing some further digging i
was able to uncover that chloe suffers
from
sibo aka small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth so sibo is a bit of a
controversial health topic
as a lot of healthcare providers don't
even believe that it's a real thing
and while i am not a specialized gi
dietitian myself
i did speak to my colleague andrea hardy
who confirmed that
it is in fact legit you can watch our
whole video on bloating specifically in
the context of a vegan diet
right here but to summarize sibo occurs
when bacteria that usually grows in your
large intestine
starts to grow in your small intestine
if left untreated
sibo can cause a lot of abdominal pain
gas diarrhea and even malnutrition
the best form of treatment is of course
antibiotics and there isn't a whole lot
of evidence that diet directly
influences sibo
but when i spoke again to andrea hardy
this week she did mention that there are
a few evidence-based diet
recommendations
for symptom management so the main ones
are to keep an eye on high intakes of
sugar and fat
make sure that you're getting enough
fiber and if necessary consider trialing
a low fodmap diet
if you need a refresher on fodmaps
definitely check out my bloating video
right here
some probiotics have also been shown to
be beneficial in some small
scale trials but you should always speak
specifically to your gastroenterologist
and dietitian to ensure that you're
using the right probiotic strain for you
i'm going to be leaving andrea's contact
information below in case you're looking
for some one-on-one advice all right now
let's see
what chloe's eating on day one
it's pretty aerated inside so there's
lots of air
and i've also made myself some blueberry
sauce
wow i mean it could be more airy
it could be more fluffy but this is
really fluffy and there's no sugar added
they're sweetener so this is like
decently high in fat and protein but not
so much carbs
oh my god i love japanese fluffy
pancakes
i like that chloe took a stab at making
these at home and
because she used a combination of almond
flour and coconut flour
her version has an impressive 20 grams
of protein and 11 grams of
fiber there's also a good amount of
heart-healthy monounsaturated fats in
there from the almond flour
but if she wants to reduce the saturated
fat while boosting up the produce and
the antioxidant content
she could definitely swap the butter on
top for some more blueberries
since this meal as it is is pretty low
carb
also both almond flour and coconut flour
are high fodmap grains
and probably fine in these modest
amounts but
just something to flag if your gut is
really sensitive
let's take a look at snack i'm gonna
have
my hot chocolate with some beef jerky
this is really hot i'm gonna give it a
swirl
okay so i like that chloe was trying to
attempt a lower fodmap
whipped coffee that everyone's making on
social media since
quarantine happened but because she used
stevia instead of powdered milk
it kind of flopped now i know i'm seeing
a lot of sugar
substitutes going on which i've talked
about when it comes to my thoughts on in
this video right here
but in chloe's case specifically i'm not
sure that this is so much like a weight
loss
diet thing as it is that she may be just
trying to manage her digestion
as consuming a lot of sugar can actually
exacerbate sibo symptoms
she also pairs her coffee with some beef
jerky so
taken together this is a pretty low carb
snack
she could definitely pair it with a
piece of low fodmap fruit if she wanted
but ultimately i mean we still have 24
grams of protein
plus 4 grams of fiber and a little bit
of fat
so i'm sure that this is pretty
saturating
the only thing to flag is that like all
jerky this
is pretty high in salt with a quarter of
your daily needs
in just a single serving so if you do
find that salt
causes bloating for you like it
definitely does for me right now
it's just something that you might want
to watch let's take a look at lunch
so i have my tofu as my bun and it
tastes so good
so you can add sriracha sauce or you can
have any sort of chili sauce as you're
dressing
but this is really tasty on its own
because this miso in
eggplant and everything is salted so
it's really good
that's kind of a fun take on a sandwich
and i get that this meal definitely
looks pretty
keto right now but interestingly due to
the sheer volume of vegetables she's
having
she's actually getting almost 60 grams
of carbs plus
27 grams of protein from the tofu
assuming that she used the 200 grams
that was in her recipe though
admittedly it does look like a lot more
she has chosen relatively lower fodmap
vegetables so those should be a little
easier on her gut
and the idea to use tofu slabs as a bun
while a little diety to me in theory
i guess it makes sense in her case um if
grains do cause discomfort
but if she wanted to switch it up she
could definitely try a gluten-free bread
or even whole wheat sourdough also one
thing to note is that both miso
and coconut aminos are both high in
sodium so again
just like to be mindful of if you're
dealing with a lot of bloating
and sodium exacerbates that let's see
dinner
and this is what i'm having having some
leftover chicken
leftover rice and also fresh vegetables
so i just fried my rice and heat up my
meat and that's it
oh my god guys the chicken tastes so
good
this black pepper chicken and it's
always better the next day
so this chicken you gotta try it out
that looks amazing i mean
we've got a nice combination of protein
from the chicken carbs from the rice
veggies from the bell pepper and greens
and some fat from the sesame oil
delicious okay now let's take a look at
her
what i eat to stop sugar cravings video
still i think i've gained a little bit
of weight i don't know
because i don't weigh myself anymore so
i don't know whether i actually gain
weight but i can
see that in my belly on my arms
but it's okay it's okay don't freak out
if you've gained a little bit of weight
because a lot of it is just water weight
and when you get back on your routine
you're gonna
lose the fat and the water weight away
so i mean
i'm at least happy to hear that chloe's
not obsessed with the scale as i feel
probably a lot of other fitness
personalities might be
and also that she enjoyed her trip in
japan and got her gelato fix
now in this video she actually shares
some of her tips to stop sugar cravings
so let's hear what she has to say about
that too
so first of all don't go cold turkey
because i feel like i used to do that in
the past i just cut them
out like completely and that
that generally did not go well after
a month or two i'll start craving for
them really badly
or i'll have the worst craving in the
first couple of days so
what i do these days is i taper it down
slowly so i
don't cut them out completely i just
have a little bit less of them and also
not so frequently so
i mean i don't love the concept of
trying to stop a particular craving by
tricking your body with some kind of
diet hack
but i would say in the world of weight
loss advice
this is at least pretty moderate
while most fitness influencers have
really dogmatic
all or nothing approaches i actually
think chloe is pretty realistic with her
advice
cutting out foods that you love almost
always backfires the moment that your
willpower runs dry so allowing yourself
moderate portions of those sweet foods
or
foods that you really enjoy throughout
the week like chloe suggests
may help prevent that restrict binge
cycle
another tip is to you know replace it
with a
healthier alternative like for example
if you really love coke
you could get like kombucha that's in
coke flavor
and that's like so low in sugar that
i'll show you guys quickly so this is
the kombucha brand that has the cola
flavor
and this is only like 1.2 grams of sugar
per 100ml
okay so i have nothing against finding
more nutrient dense swabs for
less nutritious foods as long as this
doesn't take away from the satisfaction
factor
and leave you pining and obsessing over
the real deal
maybe cola flavored kombucha is an
acceptable swap for chloe
but to someone who is really in love
with coke
it might just cause what i call the
craving scavenger hunt
you know you want the coke so you drink
the kombucha and that doesn't satisfy so
then you eat the pack of rice chips
then you eat some dark chocolate then
you have a bowl of berries then you have
a pint of low calorie ice cream
in the end had you just drank the
regular coke and called it a day
you would have taken in far fewer
calories and
gotten what you actually wanted and
moved on
i definitely think that this can work
for some people in particular
situations or it may perpetuate the
obsession
further for other people but anyways
let's see what she's having
for breakfast
love this idea of mung bean porridge
especially with the sweet
red bean paste in there i mean this
looks like a really great breakfast that
also looks pretty well balanced
the combination of beans here actually
yields about 30 grams of protein
and 90 grams of carbs plus a little bit
of fat
and her entire fiber needs for the day i
mean there's probably room for a little
bit more fat here
but i also acknowledge that for chloe
maybe eating more low-fat feels better
to her gut
in the context of hercibo let's take a
look at snack
my favorite chocolate flavor from
pineapple chocolate
and also had a little bit of this
this dark chocolate is a lot less in
sugar compared to that
so yeah they are healthier than just you
know cadbury
or lint those are a lot sweeter and
those are just like pure sugar
so that's i guess sticking to my rule
number two what's number two
to choose the healthiest alternative to
the food that you like hey
sometimes we just need a little
chocolate fix right
and while these definitely look like
higher quality chocolates because you
know they're organic and vegan and the
ingredient list looks pretty simple
not to mention of course that dark
chocolate is naturally lower in fog maps
when compared to
milk she does specifically say that
they're healthier than
cadbury or lint which are just pure
sugar
so i thought we would take a quick look
now per 100 grams the loving earth bar
has
24 grams of sugar and the panna has 44.
cadbury milk chocolate has 56 grams of
sugar
cadbury dark has 50. lint milk has
40 grams and lint dark chocolate has 30
grams
so chloe i would say yes and no
in fact the dark lint has less sugar
than the panna if we're really gonna
nitpick here but honestly
why are we splitting hairs on
chocolate's nutritional merits
i say eat what you like if you like
premium dark eat dark
if you like grocery store milk chocolate
eat that
chocolate is meant to be enjoyed so
don't force yourself to eat a certain
type in the name of
health i don't like dark chocolate at
all
so i would rather have no chocolate than
make myself
eat dark anyways chocolate rant over for
the day
let's take a look at lunch
this is a beautiful meal i mean we've
got protein from the tofu
carbs from the rice fat from the sesame
oil
and lots of beautiful vegetables in
there
so balanced and i love all that color i
mean
it honestly looks almost too good to eat
chloe also
shares some information with her
followers about how to reduce the
glycemic load of white rice
and that my friends is the food science
magic
we call retrogradation so i talked about
this in my greg ducette video but
basically when rice is cooked with a fat
and cooled
the rice forms new structures that are
more digestion
resistant meaning they contain less
available carbohydrates for our bodies
to digest and absorb
one study found that resistant starches
could be increased
by 10 times and could cut the calories
in the rice by around 50 to 60 percent
i did a whole blog on this process if
you're interested so i will definitely
link it below in the description if you
want to check it out
let's see what other diet tips chloe
gives tip number four
try to not skip your meals when you skip
your meals you
tend to cave into your cravings potato
chips and chocolates are just
so much easier to reach to instead of a
properly cooked meals because
they are pre-packaged no [ __ ] that is a
lot easier to just
grab it and eat it but actually you just
need some proper food
with good nutrition good balance of
carbs protein and fat so
if you don't skip your meals then it is
a lot less likely that you're gonna
cave into your sugar cravings or your
savory cravings whatever it is
that you crave for because then you have
time to cook for your meals
and have proper meals and the reason why
some people
shouldn't skip meals some people not
everyone is because they tend to reward
themselves
after they skip a couple meals because
they think that they deserve to have
a big pizza or lots of sweet treats and
pasta and pizza
all in one go because that's good so
chloe warns against
skipping meals because it can cause you
to cave into your cravings
or reward yourself in the form of a big
cheat meal
i actually do agree though i would
probably use different language
but sometimes i like to tell people to
think about their body kind of like a
car
when you let your car run on empty you
might get
desperate and have to pull over at a
sketchy or overpriced gas station
but if you were to keep an eye on the
gauge and fill up when you're just
starting to get low
you can be a lot more choosy about the
quality or the price of the fuel that
you buy
letting yourself get ravenous also just
doesn't
feel good and often leads to less
satisfying and satiating food decisions
i mean of course sometimes it's going to
happen because
we are human and we're just busy but
it's important to make eating a priority
and plan to have meals and snacks
whenever you can
tip number five is when you're craving
for something
sweet to drink have some tea have some
fruit infused drinks or some cold tea
they are normally
very satisfying like that's what i do
anyway when i'm really really
craving for something sweet to drink
like because you know i like my sweet
treats so sometimes i want like a hot
chocolate
or i'll make some tea okay so
i say hydration is so important
especially now that we're in the summer
months
so finding ways to make water more
appealing
is never a bad idea in my books i don't
believe that that means that you should
never
allow yourself a sweetened drink again i
think that that just dichotomizes food
as good and
bad and ultimately may make you want
them and
crave them more but i also do get that
for chloe's case specifically
higher sugar snacks and drinks may
exacerbate her sibo
especially since that sugar is more
rapidly absorbed in a pre-digested drink
like a milkshake
or sweetened frappuccino than in let's
say a piece of cake that contains some
protein and some fat
but for her general audience who are
just watching now as i do know from just
looking
at her description here that these tips
to stop sugar cravings
are within the context of trying to lose
weight or
dieting i would say that this tip
particularly
almost counteracts her earlier tip to
not quit certain foods cold turkey
yes of course we should be getting the
majority of our hydration
from water and from water rich foods
but i just don't think that even in the
context of weight loss
telling somebody to never have a sugary
drink is realistic
or necessarily helpful let's take a look
at dinner
this looks delicious we've got lots of
low fodmap high fiber veg plus some
carbs in the noodles and sweet potatoes
i would say however that this meal is
really low in protein and fat which is
five grams and one gram respectively
so if we want to boost that up we could
add some edamame and a drizzle of sesame
oil on top
but of course her breakfast and her
lunch were pretty protein
rich so in the grand scheme of her day
probably not a big deal and otherwise
looks like a
really delicious and nourishing and
comforting meal
let's finish off by addressing some of
those last few die tips of the day
tip number six is to have a balanced
diet i've been on a couple of diets
before like i've tried keto i've tried
intermittent fasting which is not really
a diet but so if you remove an entire
food group from your diet
there's a high chance that you will
crave for those foods
again this is very different for every
individual so you just got to know
what's best for you personally for me
i don't think it's good for me to remove
carbs from my diet or
fat entirely from my diet so i like to
have a balanced meal of you know carbs
fat
and protein and that really keeps me
satiated personally when i was on keto
after i got off it i was craving a lot
of sugar so
i didn't like that okay so i totally
agree
100 this is what i always talk about you
know getting
a combination of fat protein and carbs
tends to result in feeling more
physically saturated
while a nice variety of foods that you
actually enjoy
promotes emotional satisfaction whenever
you cut something out of your diet that
you genuinely enjoy
it tends to result in an obsession and
ultimately
a binge this is why chloe says that she
could really never diet since
restricting carbs on keto for example
made her crave sugar
like mad honestly i'm not surprised
i'm gonna have a little bit of this and
i'm gonna head out to see my friend and
maybe have a gelato
but today is the last day that i'm gonna
eat
like crab if i were to eat like crab
when i'm going out
it's totally okay to treat myself or
treat yourself
don't don't feel guilty that's that's
not what you're supposed to feel
don't feel guilty just enjoy the moment
enjoy your food
enjoy your friends company and yeah
um yeah this statement here feels a
little contradictory
i mean we don't have to look at a less
than perfect meal as
eating like crap we don't have to label
it as good or bad or give it a moral
identity
we can just see it as a meal thoroughly
enjoyed and one that provided a lot of
emotional satisfaction and fun with
friends
and the story drink your water drink
your water because sometimes you're just
thirsty so that's the final final final
tip sometimes you're just thirsty
again i like and don't like this
statement
yes to drinking water hydration is so
important and i think
a lot of us would feel a lot better if
we drank enough fluids in our day
largely because it can help with
regularity but as i discussed in my
video on all things adrian
there's actually no evidence to suggest
that thirst commonly
masks hunger this is just diet culture
folklore these are actually completely
different sensations and communication
mechanisms
so yes drink your water but don't use
calorie free fluids as a way to quiet
your genuine
hunger cues pay attention to how each
sensation
feels and how the experience of
satisfying
both of those needs can make you feel
i don't think that there's actually any
harm in having a big glass of water
before a meal to quench your thirst
and i don't think that chloe was
actually suggesting explicitly that you
drink
copious amounts of water to stretch your
stomach and specifically silence your
hunger cues
but this is something that comes up a
lot in diet culture
so i wanted to just make sure that i
flagged it so that it wasn't interpreted
in a really problematic way
let's take a look at day three so in
this what i in a day video
chloe specifically calls out that this
video is different because it is
a realistic wedding in a day i mean
i'm glad to hear it's a genuine
representation of what she would eat
because
isn't that kind of the point of these
vlog videos
anyway if i want super pretty food
i will look at a food blog or a recipe
video
if i want realistic i want to watch a
vlog
but anyways let's get into the video
starting with a little tip
on how to lose weight eat less
to lose weight eat more to gain weight
i mean yes but it's really not
that simple i'm gonna do a whole video
on metabolic adaptation but
very briefly put there are a lot of
reasons why
weight cannot be reduced to a simple
mathematical equation
every individual's needs are super
unique
and we all have specific set point
ranges where our body
feels best when we eat less or move more
our body has a number of mechanisms to
help preserve
its preferred weight like increasing
hunger hormones
quieting satiety hormones and reducing
our daily activity levels
the same things happen but opposite when
we try to overeat to gain a lot of
weight
it is a lot more complicated than just
that but
i just want to point out that for most
people it is not
as simple as just eat less than chloe to
lose weight or eat more than chloe to
gain weight
let's see what she has to say about her
gut supplements my severe
bloating issues i have really
problematic guts
so right now i normally take a gut
relief powder in the morning
along with vitamin c so i just mix these
two together
and i also take some probiotic before i
eat anything in the morning
my new doctor asked me not to take
probiotic yet until i see her
so she asked me to take some pre-bikes
so
that's what i've been doing and it
doesn't bloat me at all so that's
great uh what blows me the most are
vegetables
yeah great so i'm glad chloe is
listening to her doctor and avoiding the
probiotics until she gets
a chance to see him and get the green
light
supplements are not benign so always
clear
anything with your healthcare provider
to ensure that they don't make matters
worse
as for the supplements that she does
take she's taking
prebiotic fiber vitamin c and a gut
relief powder
all of which i consulted andrea hardy on
now the prebiotic fiber specifically
contains
sun fiber which is one of the most
researched
partially hydrolyzed gora gums that
andrew herself specifically recommended
to me on our chat
one study found that when combined with
rifaximin antibiotic
it eradicated sibo by 85
as for the other two the gut relief
powder contains a number of prebiotic
fibers and natural ingredients
that don't have the robust research to
back them up like sun fiber does
and i wasn't able to find any use for
vitamin c specifically for sibo
so andrea's suggestion was to stick with
the sun fiber and to limit
self-prescribed supplements and
over-the-counter medication
without her doctor's recommendation
let's take a look at breakfast
i'll make it a little bit better i
thought i have a thumbnail for it
right sorry yum
i love her honesty on the pretty factor
i mean
we do it too even if we're not really
trying but this looks great
we've got protein fat and fiber from the
almond butter
and some carbs and fiber from the fruit
and oats and girl
like it does look really pretty
let's take a look at lunch and i love
eating salmon skin because
it's always so crispy so this is the
warm version of salad
i have vegan cheese on top
i can have this every day and i feel
like i've been having it
almost every other day because i i
really love cucumbers
and now i'm gonna have some this is like
seriously my favorite chocolate ever
this is my
second favorite flavor i prefer the
other flavor but i ran out because i
have
chocolate almost every day that looks so
good we've got healthy fats from the
salmon and the olive oil including
omega-3s
protein from the salmon and lots of
fiber from the veg
and since her main meal is relatively
low in carbs i mean we could definitely
throw in some potatoes or sweet potatoes
or something like that
having some of that premium chocolate
for dessert
does round things out well of course her
main meal
is relatively low in carbs we could
totally throw in some rice or some sweet
potatoes or potatoes or something like
that
but if she was really craving the
chocolate i mean
having some of that premium pound of
chocolate for dessert in there
is another way to round things off i
also
really love that chloe knows her body
and how it responds to a lot of
raw veg so she opted to cook the veg
because it basically
pre-digests the vegetables a little bit
to a degree
which makes them easier on the gut i
also love that she started with just one
piece of salmon
but she ended up eating two because she
was just genuinely more hungry
that day this is a great example of
listening to your body and those
internal cues
rather than the external cues of just
what is on your plate
let's see her snack having some jello
so i always make these protein jelly
i'm gonna have this before i make my
dinner because it's just so hot and i
just want something cold to cool myself
down
right now so i have no clue what is in
this protein jello though the color is
amazing but it does sound like chloe was
just looking for something cool
and refreshing and was ultimately just
listening to her body
in that heat so when i have like
blueberries or strawberries
too much of it it will give me cramps
and i'll wake up with a swollen face the
next day so
i'm like really unfortunate when it
comes to
my sensitivity to food which is really
annoying because i love all these foods
but i still have them because
i'm like screw it okay screw it i'm just
gonna have it
so a lot of people ask me how to eat
intuitively with a food intolerance so i
actually answered that question
in a little bit more detail in our
principle three and five
intuitive eating right here but in short
sometimes even though the data that
you've collected on how certain foods
make you feel may say
hey i get diarrhea when i eat a lot of
ice cream eating ice cream
wouldn't be failing at intuitive eating
the key is to just move on without guilt
or shame and without insisting that you
then restrict
or punish yourself as a result sometimes
this knowledge may deter you from having
a
craving for something that doesn't feel
good and sometimes
the emotional satisfaction for a food
trumps the physical
outcomes that you may get from it
ultimately food is a really personal
thing
and when it comes to food intolerances
sometimes there's a little bit of like a
risk
benefit analysis that has to be made all
right
let's take a look at what's for dinner
so this is just a little bit of soy
sauce with kelp and rice
was a bit of the fish sauce the prawn
sauce which is
really good oh my god i'm so impressed
by myself
seriously and all these vegetables are
for me
it's actually quite a lot i love
vegetables man like
i can have a big bowl of vegetables very
easily
but i can't because i'll bloat
i seriously think that i need to have a
cookbook because i think i'm that good
in cooking
pretty solid meal here and even though
this one is much lower in fat
her lunch more than made up with it with
the olive oil and the salmon in there so
that is
definitely fantastic but here we have a
little fat from the coconut oil
some carbs from the rice protein in the
shrimp
and lots of low fodmap veg as well
she also mentions that she loves to
marinate her shrimp in ginger to reduce
bloating and improve digestion
which may potentially help because
ginger has been shown to help speed up
stomach
emptying to help reduce indigestion now
that we've gone through the three days
let's get into our big questions is this
diet
balanced generally speaking i think it
looks pretty great chloe's calories
range from around 1700 to 2100 calories
a day
and her macronutrient distribution does
vary
quite significantly just depending on
her meals which
is fine in my books i mean that to me is
actually
usually a pretty good sign that chloe is
just listening to her body needs
which will naturally vary from day to
day we're also seeing her meet her fiber
needs without going
crazy which is advisable for somebody
struggling with
sibo and for the most part she also
seems to be meeting her micronutrient
needs as well
aside from the prebiotic vitamin c and
gut health supplements
we didn't really hear her talk a lot
about taking any other vitamins
so she may benefit from an omega-3 on
days that she's not having a rich source
like salmon
and possibly a little bit more iron and
vitamin d3
if her non-dairy milk is not fortified
but really i love that we're seeing a
nice range of protein sources from the
shrimp
to tofu to beans a variety of carbs like
rice sweet potatoes oats and noodles
and a good variety of low fodmap
vegetables that she can tolerate
in terms of fat i would say her diet is
relatively low in fat
however if we want to increase the
variety of fats in our diet
i would love to see some more
plant-based options maybe some
low-fodmap pecans or walnuts or some
sunflower seeds or
pumpkin seeds now are there any
problematic claims or assumptions
made on this channel so when i went
hunting through her youtube
website and instagram i noticed for the
most part we're
seeing mainly home exercise videos which
i know are totally really helpful for a
lot of people right now
myself included i will say however that
she does
use a lot of diet culture language
around fat burning
and getting snatched and getting abs
which
i get is what a lot of people are
looking for but if you are looking for a
workout program that is a little more
inclusive
and less aesthetically focused i will
leave a few names below of fitness
youtubers or instagramers
that i think have a little bit more of a
body positive spin
there's also a lot of before and after
anecdotal transformation images and
videos on our channel
which for some people may feel
empowering but for a lot of others
it may be triggering so i am personally
not a fan of before and after photos
because i believe they invite a lot of
social comparison
and often are used as a way to measure
our own self-worth
this isn't even getting into the world
of photo manipulation which
we know is the norm online it shouldn't
then be surprising that a 2015 study
found that
looking at fitspiration images online
resulted in
worse mood body dissatisfaction and
lower self-esteem
fitspiration posts in general reinforce
the common belief
that a good body is a fit body when
real health is actually about so much
more than how toned your stomach may
look
i also want to quickly touch base on
chloe's free fitness programs
that she offers on her website a lot of
which have really sensationalized titles
like
28 day flat tummy challenge and summer
shred challenge etc
in one video i saw where she was
reviewing one of her followers progress
she admitted that these are just flashy
names and that
in reality it might take people a lot
longer than
a month or whatever to get a flat tummy
we need to stop making suggestions that
anyone can get a flat tummy period
even if that means having a less
marketable program name
now in terms of commitment i will say
her programs are not
hugely overwhelming they range from 10
to 50 minutes a day
including warming up and cooling down
and a lot of them
are only half an hour long which i think
is realistic for the average user
she also has built-in rest days so i'm
happy to see that she's not telling
anyone to jump into like a two-hour
workout regime
to get supposedly shredded so all of
this is really great in my books
so generally speaking i think chloe
largely stays in her own lane
and isn't communicating really
problematic misinformation
even if the obvious focus of her channel
is on weight loss and fat loss which you
know
is not my style and that's fine i mean
this is why we have different youtubers
for different populations finally what
can we take away from chloe's channel
that we
really really like well one thing is
that on her faq of her program
she specifically encourages her
followers to not pay attention
to the scale she even mentions that
feeling stronger
more confident and happier makes a huge
difference in your everyday life
and those are things that people often
forget about
i also love when the success stories on
your instagram
are prefaced with the disclaimer to not
compare your progress
with someone else's because everyone is
different
and it's all dependent on so many
different factors
it would be really easy for her to sell
snake oil and insist that anyone who
follows her program will
drop weight really super fast but i
appreciate that she's at least
trying to keep it real even her
non-realistic what in a day videos
feature recipes that don't take too long
to cook
and are made with generally inexpensive
accessible ingredients
bottom line in the grand scheme of
fitness influencers
i think chloe is relatively moderate in
her approach
i don't see her cutting out full food
groups for the sake of getting
lean and she seems to eat largely in
response to her hunger cues
and the data that she's gathered about
her sibo and digestive distress
well folks that is all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below about who i
should be reviewing next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you